i've got thoughts to wrap up the end of
capaldi's run but before i can do that i
need to satisfy the part of my brain
that needs to rank these things
it's time to rank the episodes in series
10 honestly doing this revisit has
reaffirmed it
is one of my favorite series of modern
era doctor who i
really do love it but i've got to give
my thoughts
from the bottom to the top reminder when
i do these kinds of rankings i do lump
together two parters as a single story
and in the case of this particular one
it's worth noting that when it comes to
the
monk trilogy i am doing extremists
separate from the other two
while i will grant that extremist sets
up the next two it is also a complete
story in and of itself
and i am going to treat it separate from
the others
okay okay let's start at the bottom with
number ten
knock knock i think it's very telling
that
what i consider to be the weakest
episode of this series
isn't actually that bad there's a reason
i said weakest and not worst
i mean technically it is the worst
relatively speaking but it's not
very bad it just feels
undercooked it feels like there's a lot
of elements that don't
really pull together and they could have
in a much more coherent way especially
given
the manner in which this series in
particular
has recurring elements of criticism of
capitalism of exploitation and they
bring in a landlord and like there is
plenty that you can say and do with a
landlord character
and they have his motivation be using
space bugs to keep his wooden mother
alive uh
i mean like points for creativity i
suppose but like you're not
mixing your elements particularly well
the haunted house vibe is
decent on it performances are okay it
just
it really feels like it
does not live up to the potential that
its component parts
had and i'm not entirely sure if the
people behind this one
realized what they could have done with
it
number nine eaters of light less an
issue of uh
unfulfilled potential and more just
straight up forgettable
to the point that i actually forgot to
put this one when i did
my big ranking list of every episode of
modern era doctor who i flat out forgot
it
so why is it not uh lower
well just because i find more things
that like
frustrate me actively about knock knock
whereas this it's just kind of in one
ear out the other it doesn't stick but
it also doesn't really frustrate me
or offend me in any particular way while
i'm watching it
and there are a couple of really great
moments along the way
they are a handful and they're not core
to the central thing but
i like the folkloric vibe to the whole
thing i like the stuff with the crows i
like
the way that the pics and the romans
finally being able to understand each
other and they realize they sound like
children there are good moments in this
but
they're not even core component parts
they're just little moments that i'm
like
i mean that's good and then the rest of
it just drops out of my head
number eight pyramid at the end of the
world
and the lie of the land this is one of
those really frustrating two-parters
where
the first half is fantastic
set up for whatever's gonna come next
but then if what comes next
doesn't deliver it just drags the whole
thing down and that's
that's basically what this is and it's
not that lie of the land itself
completely face plants or drops the ball
in every area but
it's doing a few too many things and it
just
doesn't pan out it takes a weird turn
about halfway through at the point when
bill
reunites with the doctor there's the
whole fake regeneration which i still
think is kind of dumb not just like as a
thing to try and tease the audience with
which halfway through your series it is
a dumb thing to try and tease your
audience with
but beyond that like within the
narrative i'm like
what are you doing why i um
you know you can see the review for my
full thoughts on that thing
but pyramid at the end of the world is a
really good
really strong really intriguing initial
setup
for the whole thing it just ends up
going
somewhere that i'm not gonna say it goes
nowhere but it's like that wasn't worth
two
parts to tell this whole thing again
some interesting ideas and again
some good moments you know things like
the opening to lie the land
with the atmosphere and the propaganda
and the sense of oppression it's really
good but it doesn't
sustain and by the end the way the
conclusion works is just kind of weird
number seven the empress of mars one of
the more
solid uh mark gatus pen scripts
from my perspective i'm usually not a
particularly big fan
of when he does doctor who and it's not
that he does badly it's that
what seems to appeal to him isn't really
what appeals to me
so when his scripts come in they tend to
leave me a bit cold
there are enough really interesting
ideas in this one i mean just the idea
of victorian
era british colonials
showing up on mars okay
i'm definitely intrigued and honestly
going back and revisiting it
i found a little bit more to appreciate
in the ways in which
the imperial mindset of the british is
coming into
inevitable conflict with the imperial
mindset of
the ice warriors and how there is
actually a little bit more commentary
going on in this conscious commentary i
do believe then i'd give it a credit for
initially
that said it still just kind of leaves
me going yep that was uh that was a nice
warrior story
cool okay and it's fine
it's fine number six
smile like here's where we start getting
into the stuff that oh
oh that's really good it does a great
job of expanding
the information we got about bill and
how she sort of takes in the world and
the way she bounces off the dock i
love i love the chemistry between bill
and capaldi it is fantastic the way
pearl mackie is able to bounce off this
particular incarnation of the doctor
it's really great and vibrant and lively
and it throws him off his game just a
little bit
like just enough to sort of keep him
from getting complacent which i like and
i love
and a lot of that is on display here and
there are some really neat ideas
in terms of the way the ai
does or fails to process how humans work
and where that gap
that lack of understanding of specific
things about humans
that is well certainly true of machines
right now and
if it carries into the future maybe has
worse consequences than we would have
thought
that's an interesting idea and i loved
that approach to i love that approach to
sci-fi in general
taking something that yeah that's a
thing and extrapolating further out
and seeing what's the extreme of this if
we go further
it's well handled there are a couple of
like weird logistical things where i'm
like
but hardly anything that drags it down
that much
number five the pilot
love the introduction of bill loved the
reintroduction of nardole i
love the idea of the doctor being a
professor i kind of wish the
series had done a bit more with it with
that rather than have it be an
occasional cutaway and things of thing
that we see
but it's fantastic as a setup i love the
entire premise
of that and it just feels nice and
i don't know it's warm is the word
that's coming to my mind and i don't
know why
but it just feels reassuring that like
other than the tardis he has a place
where he's coming back to
and actually has a place that he kind of
belongs
the idea that the perpetual traveler has
something approximating a home and yet
he's still restless and can't stick
around because
he's the doctor naturally you know there
are little things like
i have a little bit of a on
how much emphasis is put on the
connection between heather and bill but
honestly i've softened on that versus
my memory of it it does still bother me
a little bit but
the performances are great the conceit
is weird and creepy and interesting and
actually i think they kind of did the
water dripping
thing as a scary element better than
waters of mars did if i'm being
completely honest
four thin ice this
is one that i i always liked it just
fine but i
really did not give this one the credit
it deserved when i had watched it
initially
it has such a strong component and
interweaving of the ideas of
well having someone like bill experience
this era
of london seeing how much more diverse
it is than she would have thought and
yet it's still lorded over
by this greedy soulless
white guy who's not an alien isn't even
being manipulated by aliens he's just
a greedy industrialist and he's gonna do
what greedy industrialists
did and still do so i feels
terrifically melded together all the
different emphasis
and again the interactions between bill
and the doctor the way bill reacts when
a kid
first of all a kid dies and the way bill
reacts
the way the doctor has to answer her
questions about that
it's speaks so much
to the way that they connect and the way
that they bond how their relationship is
built over the course of this series
this is a really good episode i feel
like it's not given as much credit as it
deserves
number three extremists
this is just this is just wonderful
science fiction like look let's be
honest the it's all fake
it's all a dream it's all simulation
that's really hard to make work
it's a cliche to be completely honest
but this
story made it feel fresh by coming at it
as the answer to a setup that i didn't
think could possibly have a workable
answer
there is a truth about the world that
no matter who finds it out
they make the decision to die they make
the decision to
exit out and not be a part of this world
anymore
what could possibly do that the fact
that you're not even real
yeah that is a good answer to a setup
that i was like
no answer is going to be worth it and
again people can debate well like not
everyone will react like that that's not
the point
the point is it's an answer that i
believe
for that setup and i didn't think they'd
come up with one
and the ma the way in which they managed
to have
the doctor kind of just lose or this
fake incarnation of the doctor because
you can't defeat them they
literally control the world it's a game
to them and they even say that literally
this is a game and yet and yet
it can still feel triumphant at the end
just because
sending the information to the actual
doctor and that
smile that smirk at the end
yeah that this
manages to go as dark as it does
and yet still feel triumphant and
hopeful at the end
mwah number two
oxygen now this is definitely one where
all of the ongoing themes and recurring
motifs across the series
about criticisms of capitalism of
oppression
of industrialism of colonialism of the
whole entire idea of taking something
that is very much going on now and
taking it to an extreme to make a point
like we saw in some other episodes this
is where it all
comes together and is done too near
perfection because anyone who makes the
decision to try and argue against this
episode being like
capitalism wouldn't actually go that
extreme it's ridiculous it's over
look it's supposed to be that is the
point of this kind of science fiction to
take something
extrapolate it out to a point that it in
fact may never
reach in order to exaggerate the
inherent
problems we already have you expand them
you blow them up
you put a magnifying glass on them so
they appear much bigger than they
actually are
and maybe bigger than they will ever be
but just so you can recognize
this problem exists the
exploitation of workers the restricting
of resources vital life you know giving
necessary resources from the people who
actually make the thing
work and viewing everyone as an asset
as a number and not as a human being
this happens this is the world we live
in and if it takes extrapolating out
to this kind of extreme to make the
point freaking do it
and on top of that the stuff with bill
when she
almost well she does kind of die for a
little bit that is
wonderfully intense they maybe overdid
it because they kind of give her two
almost sort of deaths maybe one more
than necessary but they're both still
really well done
and the way the doctor is able to turn
this around
and bring it to a satisfying conclusion
just by defiance and saying hey we are
going to make it more expensive for you
to ignore us than to deal with us
yes yes i love
this episode so so much
doesn't hit number one though and number
one really should not come as a surprise
to anybody world enough in time and the
doctor falls
historically i have considered world
enough in time to be the superior of
these two parts
and while it is still really good and is
incredibly deeply painful to watch
what happens to bill and it is so creepy
and it is
perfectly executed slow build
horror the doctor falls
is as far as i am concerned a
masterpiece of summation of who
the doctor in general and capaldi's
doctor in specific
is and why he does what he does i do
what i do because it's right
because it's decent
and above all it's kind and giving him
the chance to vocalize that directly by
confronting the master
but also giving the chance to show it it
is both showing and telling
and sometimes people will say well if
you show you don't need to tell it but
when the dialogue is this good and when
the delivery is this good
from someone like capaldi you let him
tell also
but then you back it up by showing how
his
compassion drives him
even if he is certain that he's not only
going to lose he's going to die
how his belief and his hope and his
faith is not always rewarded
he told bill that he could save her but
he can't
he thought he could but he can't and he
has to own up to that
even the conclusion with heather i have
come around on for the most part
a couple of tiny [ __ ] about that but
even that taking
a revisit and re-examination of that and
i'm no
that it works it all works honestly the
only thing holding this back is the fact
that this should have been the actual
regeneration
instead of setting up twice upon a time
but other than that
this is doctor who
in general and as a closing
story in particular at its best
i love series 10 and i adore
this ending it's actually i think
fairly uncommon for doctor who to end on
its
strongest note in any given series but
it does here
and i love it my ranking
for series 10 what do you think how
would you rank them whatever your
thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon
that is what keeps this entire thing
going and there are rewards for every
tier
from access to a discord to getting to
participate in polls and seeing the
docket for what i plan to do
in upcoming months to getting your name
in the credits which you'll be seeing a
little bit
but if you're not able to do that
there's youtube memberships as well
also just like share subscribe it all
helps me out and grows the channel
and keeps the algorithm from burying me
which it
likes to do sometimes often
but you also don't have to do any of
that because at the end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
bye